[Musique]
oui on est aligné dans la bonne
direction on devrait pouvoir conclure
dans les semaines qui viennent des bons
accords mais c'est une rencontre de
travail ce sera pas le moment de
célébrer
Dominique Leblanc bonjour Merci d'être
des nôtres
cette semaine on l'a entendu dans
l'extrait il y a quelques secondes
monsieur Trudeau semble très très près
d'une entente en matière de santé avec
avec les collègues des provinces et des
territoires qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
depuis la ministre de la rencontre des
ministres de la santé avant couvert où
tout le monde avait l'air à couteau
tirer moi je pense les premiers
ministres et notre gouvernement on a
travaillé depuis les rencontres avant le
couvert de l'automne passé monsieur
Trudeau a parlé à plusieurs premiers
ministres dans le Premier ministre le
goal le Premier ministre moi j'en ai
parlé moi-même à plusieurs premiers
ministres on comprend que les Canadiens
veulent voir une entente qui va
améliorer le système de soins de santé
on voit la pression moi j'ai passé deux
mois comme résident à l'hôpital
Maisonneuve-Rosemont à Montréal je
connais les gens qui travaillent dans
cet hôpital là on connaît à travers le
pays des gens qui travaillent dans le
système de soins de santé la pression
est énorme les Canadiens sont inquiets
avec raison ils veulent voir les
gouvernements pareil pour trouver des
solutions on a toujours dit qu'on était
prêt à investir davantage un financement
fédéral mais on veut juste nous assurer
assurer les contribuables canadiens que
ces investissements vont amener de
meilleurs résultats un accès accru vont
alléger les difficultés en termes de
personnel dans les hôpitaux et nous
voyons énormément de bonnes volonté de
la part des premiers ministres pour
discuter les meilleures façons d'arriver
à ces résultats-là ensemble et le
Premier ministre a décidé que c'était un
bon moment d'inviter ces homologues à
une discussion quand est-ce que vous
êtes dit on parle plus de normes
nationales parce que pendant un bout de
temps il y a deux discours du Trône on
va imposer des normes nationales aux
provinces là on parle de priorité on
parle de travailler ensemble quand
est-ce que vous êtes dit ok on va
reculer un peu sur celle-là ça faisait
partie des discussions entre les paliers
de gouvernement vraiment du Québec était
très clair comme d'autres provinces qui
voulaient collaborer mais vous voulez
pas que une situation soit imposée
d'Ottawa pour utiliser votre mot
jamais été notre volonté dans le sens on
veut s'assurer que les investissements
fédéraux des contribuables canadiens
amènent des améliorations c'est la
volonté des provinces aussi alors si on
peut s'assurer par exemple dans la
question des données qui a une
transparence envers les citoyens et
contribuables voici l'argent donné par
les gouvernement puis voici les
résultats qu'on est allé obtenir avec
cet argent là mais ça va bénéficier tout
le monde et ça devient incitatif pour
tout le monde dans le système d'avoir
des meilleurs résultats et c'est ça que
les gouvernements souhaitent ensemble
vous avez parlé de retour sur
l'investissement l'argent les provinces
disent il nous faut 28 milliards que
c'est raisonnable je traduit j'ai une
idée j'ai un montant en tête une
proposition qui lui qualifie raisonnable
28 milliards et raisonnable qu'est-ce
qui est raisonnable je pense c'est de
s'asseoir avec les premiers ministres
des provinces comme ils ont demandé
depuis longtemps et de partager avec eux
une proposition
y compris des montants que nous allons
proposer aux provinces et c'est 50
milliards c'est une grosse majoration se
rendent dans les eaux de 28 milliards
pas de doute c'est une grosse majoration
compte tenu de cette année seulement les
transferts vont augmenter d'entre 9 et
10 % basés sur le format actuel ça c'est
4 milliards de dollars cette année de
nouvel argent et ça bâtit en perpétuité
dans le formulaire alors il y a des
augmentations déjà très importants qui
vont se faire mais les détails de quel
montant et quelle structure ça va être
ça la discussion parallèlement à la
rencontre sur la santé et Madame féline
votre collègue qui elle travaille sur le
budget vous avez de moins en moins de
marges de manœuvre l'économie va pas
très bien on parle de plus en plus de
récession
avez-vous de la place dans ce budget là
pour ces majorations là pipe pour aider
davantage les Canadiens qui pour en
avoir besoin oui on aura de la place
dans le budget fédéral pour encadrer une
entente si on arrive à la bonne entente
avec les provinces pour les soins de
santé est-ce que ça va vouloir dire
couper ailleurs il va falloir il va
falloir restreindre les dépenses à un
moment donné non peut-être il y a pas de
question de couper beaucoup des
programmes qu'on a vu dans la période la
pandémie arrive et sont arrivés déjà à
la fin on va investir davantage sur la
transformation de l'économie vers une
économie durable ça c'est une priorité
mais il faudra que le gouvernement
regarde étant donné la situation
financière regarde nos priorités en
termes de qu'est-ce qui est urgent cette
année qu'est-ce qu'on pourra peut-être
faire l'année prochaine ou l'année
d'après qu'est-ce qui pourrait être
relégué à l'année prochaine l'année
d'après c'est ça le processus budgétaire
que Madame freelance que vous avez une
série de meeting cette semaine pour moi
je connais pas les demandes budgétaires
en détail de toutes mes collègues
communistes de l'infrastructure c'est
sûr j'ai une bonne la conversation avec
Madame Freeling en ce qui a créé au
portefeuille de l'infrastructure mes
collègues font la même chose et le
Premier ministre c'est Madame freelone
vont décider au cours des prochaines
semaines dans le processus budgétaire
vous connaissez bien le processus mais
donc vous vous êtes fait dire modérez
vos attentes un peu c'est ça a été très
transparent publiquement alors de nos
rencontres hamleton la semaine passée
elle a dit que la situation financière
cette année sera plus serré que
peut-être on aurait attendu il y a deux
trois ans alors toutes les ministres et
tous les programmes gouvernementaux vont
être examinés à travers cette analyse là
pour prenez les travaux parlementaires
cette semaine retour en chambre et là il
y a une série de projets de loi qui sont
toujours sur la table qui auraient dû à
certains égards être adoptés il y a déjà
longtemps
question vos priorités qu'est-ce que
vous voulez faire adopter rapidement
écoutez n'importe quel mesure qui va
aider les Canadiens en termes d'abord
d'habilité en termes du coût de la vie
on a devant le Parlement des mesures
budgétaires de l'année passée toutes les
mesures financières qui vont aider les
familles du Canada toutes les mesures
qui sont essentielles par exemple dans
la lutte contre des changements
climatiques de ma prioritaire la
question des langues officielles pour
nous est une grande priorité vous n'avez
promis en 2015 c'est encore c'est très
bon
en 2015 on a une réforme de la on avait
proposé un projet de loi au dernier
Parlement on a réintroduit le projet
actuel pour le moment c'est bloqué en
comité nous avons un gouvernement
minoritaire il faut travailler avec les
parlementaires on a eu des bonnes
discussions avec le NPD moi je suis pas
pessimiste que dans les prochains mois
on va adopter le projet de loi qui va
vraiment moderniser d'une façon
importante la Loi sur les langues
officielles quand j'ai d'été moi je
l'espère moi je l'espère que même avant
Pâques si on est chanceux vraiment sur
le convoi des camionnettes centre ville
de tarot il y a exactement un an cette
fin de semaine qu'est-ce qui a changé
d'après vous mais moi j'étais ici
pendant ces semaines là ça faisait aucun
bon sang qu'est-ce qui se passait au
centre-ville d'une capitale d'un pays du
G7
la frustration des gens au début je
pense a été énormément motivé par des
mesures sanitaires quand ce qui a trait
à la lutte contre la covid à la fin il y
avait toutes sortes de frustrations
franchement qui a bien des égards
étaient pas beaucoup attaché à la
réalité il y a pas d'autres que la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence à donner une
façon d'amener à une conclusion et une
conclusion paisible on va le rapport du
juge rouleau au cours des prochaines
semaines on a hâte avoir non seulement
son analyse de qu'est-ce qui est arrivé
mais c'est recommandations quand on
mesure passer pour éviter un recours à
la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence
advenant à une telle manifestation qui
devient illégale et qui occupe du
centre-ville est-ce que on a beaucoup
parlé du discours politique qui enflammé
ces gens-là est-ce que est-ce que vous
est-ce que votre premier ministre porte
une part de responsabilité dans le type
de mots dans le titre de discours qui a
été mené qui est peut-être enflammé ces
gens-là je pense pas monsieur Trudeau a
amené des team bits du café aux
manifestants comme Monsieur pollièvre
pas vu monsieur Trudeau serait un pont
en train de saluer l'arrivée de ces
gens-là qui allait hurler des insultes à
des femmes à des personnes racialisées
puis occuper une centre-ville moi je
crois que la frustration avec les
mesures nécessaires dans le contexte
d'une pandémie
à AG énormément de gens on comprend ça
les gens étaient tannés frustrés en
accepta mais ça justifie pas du tout le
comportement de qu'est-ce qui est arrivé
au fil de trois semaines à Ottawa merci
beaucoup merci à vous monsieur Thibault